(rock music)
- Do you watch Toddlers and
Tiaras, does anybody watch that?
Yeah?
(cheering)
It's about the child pageants.
Which is a very American
thing, child beauty pageants.
Is anybody not from
America at all in here?
One of you?
Are you all American?
'Cause I'd explain
it in Canada people,
'cause they don't like,
they don't know what it is.
They don't do that.
So you have to
explain to foreigners.
(laughter)
Okay, look, here's what it is.
In America, we have
beautiful children
so, yeah there you go.
(laughter)
We have to have a contest
because we have hot kids,
I don't know, what do
you want me to tell you?
Sorry if you're not going
through the same thing.
(beaver squeals)
(laughter)
Hey, sorry to hear about your
unfuckable children Canada.
(laughter)
We got to live our lives.
It is weird though, and so
this one mom got in trouble
because she put big fake tits
on her five year old daughter.
(laughter)
Well it was for the
talent part of the show.
(laughter)
She didn't have a talent.
Quick, we need a talent.
Big fake tits and
a big fake ass,
and she comes out and
does a booty ass for the
And she got in legal trouble.
She might lose custody of
her daughter for that now.
Which is so unfair, because
that woman is genius.
That's really, that's
the most amazing
thing I've ever heard of.
Tits on a five year
old at a pageant?
(laughter)
You've never thought
of anything that good
in your whole life dude.
(laughter)
You've never once had
an idea that good, ever.
What's the big fear
about these pageants?
It's pedophiles,
pedophiles right?
So what better way to hide
your child from a pedophile
(laughter)
than to disguise her
as a voluptuous lady.
(laughter)
That is, they don't
want to see that!
Big ass titties!
(applause)
Pedophiles hate that.
That's like ruining the whole
point of being a pedophile.
(laughter)
I bet every pedophile left
that pageant in disgust.
Shame on you ma'am.
(laughter)
That is a child, a
beautiful, beautiful child.
That's gross.
But that's what a
pedophile says, you know.
That's not me saying that.
That's what a
pedophile says, I don't
say things like that.
I'm like, Hey,
let's get some tits
on this kid and
get her out there.
See what she can do.
(laughter)
I'm like the opposite
of a pedophile.
I like kids with fat tits.
I'm not going to apologize
for not being a pedophile.
Do you ever watch
the adult pageants?
Adult beauty pageants?
But just when they
have to answer
questions, and they sound dumb?
Yeah, that's mean, that's
mean, you're mean to do that.
Remember Miss Utah, who was
on YouTube just recently?
'Cause she answered,
they asked her a question
and she said, Women
need to do more better.
Something like that.
Everybody was making fun of her.
And women do need
to do more better.
She's not wrong.
(laughter)
You don't need to
do more better?
But, why would you
ask those questions
at a beauty pageant?
Why are there smarty pants
questions at a pretty contest?
I think that is the question.
That's not fair.
What's the point of
having fake tits if I have to
know things on top of that?
You can tell me what
that money's for.
You can't just be a
specialist, that's not allowed?
That's not fair.
(laughter)
That's like if you took
Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
that is the second woman
in history ever nominated
to the Supreme Court.
That's a very high achievement.
And she's a role
model for girls, okay?
And if at the hearing,
Okay Ruth Bader Ginsburg,
great legal answers, great job.
But now we are coming
to the swimsuit
portion of the confirmation.
So you're going to have
to put this two-piece on.
(laughter)
And let's see how
well rounded you are.
Yeah, you know about
the law, woop de doo.
She comes out all
nervous, kinda.
And just point, yeah,
that's your beach body,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg?
Do you think you're going to be
a Justice with those tits?
Is that what you thought?
You're a role model.
(rock music)